Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Wir müssen aber unserer Fußballkultur treu bleiben. Mit Fußballkultur treu bleiben meine ich eben, dass wir eben keine Halbzeitkonzerte machen, dass wir eben nicht irgendwelche großartigen Events um das Spiel machen. Ich glaube, Deutschland genauso wie England, da geht es wirklich um das Fußballspiel. Da geht es wirklich um diese 100 mal 60 Quadratmeter. Man möchte seinen Verein siegen sehen, man möchte den Rivalen bezwingen am langen Ende. Darum geht das.
Die Fußballkultur in Deutschland, wie soll sie aussehen? Wir hörten ein Zitat von Max Eberl, das er dem Kicker gegeben hat, vor zwei Jahren nun schon. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen in diesem Tribünengespräch der besonderen Art. Warum, das erkläre ich gleich. Mein Name ist Max Sagobost, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich, dass ihr mal wieder mit dabei seid. Ja, warum ein Tribünengespräch der besonderen Art? Das hier ist das zweite Tribünengespräch, das wir vor Live-Publikum aufgezeichnet haben, das aber im Gegensatz zu der damaligen Folge, das war Tribünengespräch Nummer 11, zur Arbeit von Fußballkommentatoren und Moderatoren diesmal nicht als Tribünengespräch angelegt hat. Das heißt, das, was ihr jetzt dann im Folgenden hören könnt, ist die Aufzeichnung einer Diskussionsrunde, die ich am Rande des 11-Millimeter-Fußballfilmfestivals halten durfte und die eben erst mal auch das sein sollte. Eine Diskussionsrunde und kein klassisches Tribünengespräch. Dementsprechend widmen wir uns zwar einem Thema sehr eingehend, aber wir kommen zu keinem Ende. Das ist vielleicht aber bei diesem Thema auch gar nicht möglich. Worum es gleich gehen soll, sage ich euch. Aber vorher muss ich noch danken den Supportern Tom1211, Steve, Michi B., Daniel T und Michael BSC. Sie alle unterstützen den Rasenfunk finanziell und machen es damit möglich, dass wir euch auch solche Sendungen hier veröffentlichen können. Vielen herzlichen Dank dafür. Wer sich darüber informieren möchte, wie man uns unterstützen kann, findet ihr alle Infos dazu. Zusätzlich muss ich bei dieser Folge aber noch einer Reihe von weiteren Menschen danken, nicht nur Supporterinnen und Supporter. Ich danke zum einen ganz herzlich Jochen vom 11mm Fußballfilmfestival-Organisationsteam. Der hat die ganze Idee einer Podiumsdiskussion in Rollen gebracht und da auch viel eigene Zeit reingesteckt. Außerdem Jan, der uns ganz, ganz herausragend vor Ort bedient hat und dafür gesorgt hat, dass für alles gesorgt war, auch für die technische Möglichkeit, das hier aufzuzeichnen. Vielen herzlichen Dank an euch beide. Dann möchte ich ganz besonders nochmal Marvin und Katharina danken, dass sie sich darauf eingelassen haben, zu diesem Thema eine Diskussionsrunde beizuwohnen. Ihr werdet in gut anderthalb Stunden wissen, warum dieser Dank sehr, sehr gerechtfertigt ist. Und dann werdet ihr auch erfahren haben, warum es auf jeden Fall sich gehört, dass ich an der Stelle nochmal dem anwesenden Publikum danke, dass sich toll eingebracht hat, dass wie geplant die Perspektive nochmal erweitert hat und neue Denkimpulse und Denkanstöße gegeben hat zu diesem Thema. Worum soll es gehen? Fußballkultur 2.0. So ist der Titel dieses Tribünengesprächs. Das ist schon einigermaßen vage, so wie ja auch der Begriff der Fußballkultur ein Wager ist. Im Großen und Ganzen habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, ist die Fußballkultur, so wie wir sie propagieren, so wie sie in vielen Medien dargestellt wird, passt das noch in unsere Zeit oder gibt es nicht da einige Leerstellen, dunkle Flecken, die da nicht ganz mit abgebildet werden, vielleicht auch Entwicklungen, die aus der neueren Zeit kommen, seien sie digitaler Natur oder seien sie gesellschaftlicher Natur. Die Zeiten haben sich verändert, die dabei ein bisschen nicht mit gemeint werden, wenn wir über den Fußball sprechen, so wie wir ihn gerne hätten. Und so schwamm ich jetzt auch schon wieder diese Formulierung war, zeigt sich auch schon, es ist ein zu großes Thema, um das in einem Tribünengespräch zu besprechen. Und allein die Definition, die jeder einzelne und jeder einzelne von euch da draußen von Fußballkultur hat, wird schon mal wesentlich ausmachen, worüber man eigentlich redet. All das werdet ihr jetzt gleich in diesem Tribünengespräch hören. Wie gesagt, es ist in Live-Qualität, das heißt, das eine oder andere Mal ist es nicht perfekt ausgesteuert. Ich denke aber, es ist dennoch sehr gut hörbar und inhaltlich. Danke ich wirklich an der Stelle nochmal den beiden Gästen, die das sehr bereichert haben. Ich wünsche euch jetzt viel Spaß. Es geht direkt los mit der Podiumsdiskussion, die am 23. März beim 11-Millimeter-Fußballfilm-Festival in Berlin stattgefunden hat.
Viel Spaß. Herzlich willkommen zu unserer Podiumsdiskussion hier heute Abend, organisiert von Max Jakob Ost, bekannt als der Gehnetzer bei Twitter. Ich bin Jochen Lohmann, ich bin hier Teil des Organisatorenteams bei 11 Millimeter, auch bekannt bei Twitter als 11mm. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass wir hier so zahlreich da sind. Ich soll nicht viele Worte sagen, weil Max möchte selber reden. Und deswegen habt viel Spaß, kommt auch mal, wenn wir einen Film zeigen. Und das machen wir manchmal und von daher, jetzt geht es weiter mit der Diskussionsrunde. Du stellst vor.
Dankeschön. Ich möchte natürlich nicht das Mikro haben nur, weil ich so viel reden möchte, sondern weil ich glaube, dass die Gäste hier so viel zu sagen haben und ich mich auf eine sehr schöne Diskussion freue. Also ich bin der Max, ich mach den Fußballpodcast Rasenfunk, darum soll es heute aber nicht gehen. Aber ich sage das deshalb, damit ihr alle wisst, eventuell wird das hier auch noch als Podcast-Aufzeichnung veröffentlicht werden im Rasenfunk. Das heißt, ich möchte gerne, dass ihr euch auch beteiligt an der Diskussion. Das heißt, in der ersten Hälfte werden wir ein bisschen sprechen und dann würde ich das gerne öffnen. Würde mich sehr freuen über viele Wortmeldungen von euch, aber tut das in dem Wissen, dass ihr eventuell vor einem, naja, etwas ein bisschen größeren Publikum dann quasi auch im Podcast auftreten würdet. Sollte euch das nicht recht sein, dann sagt ihr mir Bescheid. Das ist auch alles noch nicht so safe. So, worüber wollen wir heute sprechen? Das Thema war ja Fußballkultur, nur etwas für alte, sentimentale Männer. Wie immer ein bisschen auf den Punkt gebracht. Der Ausgangspunkt ist so ein bisschen. Wenn wir uns wünschen würden, was für ein Fußball wollen wir haben, dann glaube ich, auch wenn wir jetzt hier eine spontane Umfrage machen würden, wären wir uns alle relativ einig. Wir hätten wahrscheinlich einen Fußball, der bodenständig sein soll, frei von Kommerz, erschwinglich, ehrlich, mit Stehplätzen, Bratwurst und Bier und am liebsten natürlich alles Samstag um 15.30 Uhr. Das ist zumindest so das Bild, von dem ich den Eindruck habe, dass es so über die Medien am häufigsten transportiert wird und das dafür vielleicht herausragendste Medium in Deutschland ist, Freunde zu nennen. Und das ist ja auch alles ein schönes Fußballbild und es ist auch alles erklärbar, woher das kommt. Weil so wurden wir, glaube ich, oder viele von uns, mit dem Fußball sozialisiert. Die Frage, die ich mir da aber gestellt habe und die ich jetzt dann gerne diskutieren wollen würde, ist, ob da nicht was fehlt. Ob wir nicht, wenn wir dieses Bild von Fußball vor uns her tragen, ein paar Teile ausblenden. Was ist mit den Frauen, die heute viel präsenter in den Stadien sind, als in den 80ern und 90ern, auf das dieses Bild sich ja irgendwie dann immer so ein bisschen bezieht. Was ist mit jungen Fußballfans, für die die Frage nicht mehr ist, ob sie es pünktlich zur Sportschau nach Hause schaffen, so war es bei mir früher noch, sondern ob sie jetzt eher Premier League gucken oder ein Spiel von Cristiano Ronaldo oder doch den Livestream vom Fifa19-Turnier. Und das soll so ein bisschen Ausgangspunkt dieser Diskussionsrunde sein. Also Ausgangspunkt ist nicht die These, das ist so, sondern es ist ein Gefühl meinerseits. Das Gefühl, dass bei dem gängigen Bild von Fußballkulturelemente fehlen und wie weit dieses Gefühl jetzt dann mit euren Gefühlen übereinstimmt, auch mit euch allen hier im Raum, das wollen wir jetzt diskutieren. Und vielleicht können wir ja damit dann ein anderes, vielleicht auch ein moderneres Bild vom Fußball zumindest anreisen. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir die Frage endgültig geklärt bekommen, was Fußballkultur heutzutage ist. Dafür reicht dann vielleicht auch die Zeit nicht. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ich zwei hervorragende Gesprächspartner dazu gewinnen konnte. Ohne die das Ganze nicht tragfähig, werde mein Part quasi schon enden. Ich begrüße zum einen bei mir Katharina Dahme, Diplompolitikwissenschaftlerin und Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender bei barwisberg 03. Und Katharina. Und zum anderen Marvin Ronsdorf, dessen Biografie alleine schon zeigt, dass er mit einer anderen Form von Fußball zu tun hat. Er startete eins mit einem Blog zu Pro Evolution Soccer. Das ist eine Fußball Simulation für alle diejenigen, die das nicht wissen. Heute ist er Partner bei Apollo 18, einer Sportmarketing Agentur und im Vergleich zu mir ist er deprimierend jung. Bevor wir so ein bisschen in die Diskussion gehen, müssen wir eine Definitionsfrage stellen. Da würde ich gerne bei dir anfangen, Marvin. Was ist denn, was meinst du denn, wenn du von Fußballkultur sprichst, ohne dass du jetzt den Begriff ausdefinieren musst? Nur deine persönliche Definition.
Also wenn ich an Fußballkultur denke, dann denke ich eigentlich vor allem daran, wie ich zum Fußball gekommen bin. Und das war noch ein Stück weit vor Pro Evolution Soccer. Und da bin ich nämlich mit meinem Onkel als Sechsjähriger halt ins Westfalenstadion gegangen. Hab mir angeschaut, wie 1860 München 3-2 gegen Borussia Dortmund gewinnt. Mit zwei Toren von Bernhard Winkler. Und trotzdem hat es mich irgendwie gepackt. Also ich bin der Borussia verbunden geblieben. Und quasi diese Atmosphäre ins Stadion zu kommen, einen Aufgang hochzugehen, auf einer Stehplatztribüne zu stehen, das war für mich immer Fußballkultur. Das ist auch für mich immer noch Fußball, dieses gemeinsam Fußball erleben. Ja, so würde ich es für mich definieren. Also gemeinsam Fußball intensiv und live erleben. Und ich glaube, wir werden ja später noch darüber sprechen, ob ich da repräsentativ für ältere oder auch für jüngere Generation bin.
Immerhin hast du 60 noch gegen Borussia Dortmund in der Liga erlebt. Das heißt, so jung bist du dann doch nicht mehr.
Beruhigend.
Katharina, was ist für dich Fußballkultur?
Ja, ich merke immer, dass wenn man über Fußballkultur spricht, dass man wahnsinnig viel reinpacken kann, was alles Fußballkultur sein könnte. Und ich habe natürlich auch so erinn, bei mir ist es auch schon sehr lange her, dass ich das erste Mal in das Stadion gegangen bin. Also ich glaube, es sind jetzt knapp 20 Jahre schon, die ich ins Stadion gehe. Und da habe ich natürlich ganz andere Verbindungen. Das, was mir heute einfallen würde, ist natürlich auch ein bisschen bedingt durch meinen Fußballverein, der ja auch einen gewissen politischen Ruf hat, dass bei mir Fußballkultur stark verbunden ist mit so politischer Außensetzung im Raum von Stadion. Also die ganze Debatte, das wäre jetzt eine eigene Debatte für sich, inwiefern hat Politik was im Stadion zu suchen. Aber bei mir ist eben immer stark auch dieser Anspruch an Fußball von Querschnitt der Gesellschaft. Da kommen wir auch gleich hin, also welche Rolle spielen da auch Frauen. Aber eben, dass du auch aus der Gesellschaft, aus den verschiedensten Schichten von Bevölkerung Leute hast, die in Stadion alle gleich sind. Das ist ja eigentlich so das Bild, wenn wir über sententliche Mentalitäten reden, was mein schönes Bild von Fußball wäre. Wie fände es gelingt oder nicht? Da verbinde ich viel mit Fußballkultur. Also was da für eine Stimmung aufkommt, wo plötzlich ganz egal ist, woher die Leute kommen.
Und da ist ja dann eigentlich schon die logische Anschlussfrage, wie glaubst du denn, hat sich das verändert? Also wenn wir davon sprechen, dass im Stadion, im Studium sind sowieso alle gleich, aber im Stadion alle gleich sind, wie würdest du die Situation heute im Vergleich zu vor 20 Jahren, wo du das erste Mal im Stadion warst, beschreiben? Auch wenn du es damals sicherlich noch nicht so reflektiert hattest.
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich bin damit nicht ins Stadion gegangen, hab gedacht, wow, ich bin ja eine von den wenigen Frauen, aber natürlich spielt es eine Rolle, dass über die Jahre, die 20 Jahre, Frauen dafür präsenter geworden sind. Insofern hat sich da, glaub ich, viel verändert, weil das ja immer auch, also die Zusammensetzung von so einem Stadion, wer geht dahin, hat natürlich einen wahnsinnigen Einfluss darauf, wie sich Fußballkultur verändert. Und ich glaube, die bloße Präsenz hat da auch einen Einfluss drauf. Ich mein, wir haben in den Stadien in den letzten Jahren ja schon viele Entwicklungen gehabt, wo es auch eine kritischere Auseinandersetzung mit Diskriminierung verschiedener Art gibt, sei es irgendwie gegenüber Frauen, sei es gegenüber aber auch, also die ganze Kampagne gegen Homophobie in den Stadien oder auch Rassismus. Das, würde ich sagen, hat dahin Frauen durch ihre bloße Präsenz eine Veränderung bewirkt. Also ich glaube, dass wir haben ja auch immer mal so diskutiert, zum Beispiel, ob es eine weibliche Sicht auf den Fußball gibt. Dass bei allen Gesprächen, die ich mit Frauen führe, mit einer Ausnahme war eine klare Antwort auf gar keinen Fall. Also in der Art und Weise, wie man Fußball betrachtet, wird nicht von Frauen oder Männern unterschiedlich betrachtet. Aber natürlich machen Frauen andere Erfahrungen im Stadion. Also auf unterschiedlichsten Ebenen. Das fängt schon daran an, dass man irgendwie das Gefühl hat, immer sich rechtfertigen zu müssen. Also alle Frauen, die ich anspreche, was bedeutet für sie, Frau im Stadion zu sein, kommen seltsamerweise immer selber so ein bisschen in die Rolle sagen zu müssen, die Frauen, die da nur sind und sich für den Fußball nicht interessieren, die nerven mich ja auch. Also immer schon so vorwegnehmen, wie könnte das Bild von Männern oder der Blick von Männern auf Frauen sein, wo ich ja nie auf die Idee kommen würde, oder ich glaube, viele nicht auf die Idee kommen würden im Stadion, wenn ein Mann einen blöden Spruch macht oder sichtbar ist, dass der irgendwie vielleicht auch mal nicht Ahnung vom Fußball hat. Ich glaube, das fällt gar nicht weiter auf. Bei Frauen fällt das eher auf oder Frauen sind eher in dem Blickpunkt zu sagen, interessiert die sich wirklich für Fußball. Die Frage stellt sich da immer automatisch mit und das habe ich auf verschiedensten Ebenen erlebt. Also selber als Zuschauerin im Stadion, in meinem Job, wo ich teilweise auch jahrelang bei 11 Freunde gearbeitet habe oder eben auch im Aufsichtsrat.
Ja, eigentlich ja völlig grotesk, denn ich musste mich noch nie von irgendwelchen Grattlern auf der Haupttribüne distanzieren. Aber das sind die auch oft geschlechtsgleich zu mir, zumindest in Ansätzen. Wenn wir jetzt dann so ein fußballkulturelles Bild aufmachen, wo jetzt meine These ist, das kommt alles so aus einer älteren Zeit, also aus den 80ern, aus den 90ern, das ist so ein bisschen da. Damals war es alles noch toll und dann wurde alles kommerziell und hat sich in Richtung entwickelt, die vielen gegen den Strich geht. Findest du, dass es da eine Leerstelle gibt, die eben zum Beispiel die Frauen im Stadium betreffen, einfach weil sie damals noch nicht so präsent waren?
Also auch für mich ist die nicht so sichtbar, weil ich mich ja im Fußball, vor allem mit dem Fußball selber beschäftige. Also insofern spielt für mich jetzt, also ich habe das nicht so spürbar, dass ich da merke, oh Gott, hier werden Frauen nicht repräsentiert, außer halt dann in den Gremien. Da merke ich es natürlich schon enorm. Also wenn ich selbst bei einem Fußballverein wie Babelsberg, wo es in Ruhe, sag ich mal, Sensibilisierung für das Thema gibt, dass irgendwie Gleichberechtigung von Frauen ein wichtiges Thema ist, ich trotzdem die einzige Frau in den Gremien bin. Und wenn ich jetzt mich entscheiden würde, nicht mehr anzutreten für den Aufsichtsrat, glaube ich, dann gäbe es auch nicht unbedingt sofort andere Frauen, die kandidieren. Oder es fällt auch mir wahnsinnig schwer, Frauen zu finden, die bereit sind, in die Gremien reinzugehen, weil es natürlich auch immer noch, also nicht so eine Überrepräsentanz gibt. Es sind natürlich auch immer noch, auch wenn mehr Frauen im Stadion sind heute, als vor zehn Jahren, ist es natürlich noch weit nicht so, dass es automatisch, also es gibt keinen Automatismus zu sagen, auch Frauen sind repräsentiert sein.
Und jetzt hast du davon gesprochen, dass du natürlich andere Erfahrungen im Stadion gemacht hast als ich und als jeder andere hier im Raum. Jeder macht so seine persönlichen Erfahrungen. Bei dir kommt eben dann der Faktor dazu, dass du schon mal so grundsätzliche Debatten führen musst über deinen Interesse zu Fußball. Was sind denn dann so Erfahrungen, die du jetzt in deiner Tätigkeit bei Babesberg machst?
Na jetzt in der Tätigkeit, also ich habe ja gesagt, es gibt unterschiedliche Stufen von dem einmal, dass man irgendwie immer erklären muss, dass man sich auch wirklich für den Fußball interessiert und nicht als Begleitung im Stadion ist. Wusstest du das immer noch? Ich persönlich nicht, ich merke es aber in Gruppen, dass es schnell so eine Dynamik gibt, dass die Frauen, die dabei sind, immer so ein bisschen unterstellt, wird sie sein die Freundin von irgendjemandem. Aber ich habe natürlich auch, also ich habe auch Auswärtsfahrten mitgemacht, wo ich die einzige Frauenbus war und wo dann die Frage nach, nee, Toilettenpause haben wir keine Zeit mehr für, ist natürlich für eine Frau eine bisschen andere Situation, als wenn die Männer sich zu helfen wissen. Im Gremium selber habe ich wirklich, das war die schlimmste Erfahrung wahrscheinlich und auch die ist noch überschaubar. Also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel selber nicht so Erfahrung von Sexismus im Stadion gemacht. Das glaube ich gibt es auch überall. Man wird auch dumm angemacht. Und ich glaube, ich wurde auch schon ein paar Mal dumm angemacht. Es ist aber als Frau relativ normal so eine Erfahrung zu machen, auch außerhalb des Stadions, deswegen fällt es mir vielleicht auch nicht mehr so auf. Im Gremium selber hatte ich eine Situation, dass ich im Wippraum im Gespräch mit jemandem war, der fragte, was ich da eigentlich mache. Und ich habe gesagt, ich bin hier im Aufsichtsrat dieses Vereins. Also es war wirklich bei uns im Stadion. Und der hat gesagt, aber Frauen haben doch hier im Fußballstadion gar nichts zu suchen. Und jetzt stellt man sich die Situation vor mit so einem Typen, der irgendwie vielleicht ein blödes Grinsen auf dem Gesicht hat und glaubt, er kann ein bisschen provozieren. Aber es war überhaupt nicht so gemeint, sondern er meinte das völlig ernst. Also er hat wirklich gesagt, geh doch nach Hause. Also was willst du denn? Hier Frauen und Fußball, das passt einfach nicht zusammen. Und das ist, glaube ich, jetzt auch noch nicht... Also ich meine, es gibt ja in den ersten vier Ligen die Sandra Schwedler vom Aufsichtsrat St. Pauli. Sie ist ja in den ersten vier Ligen neben mir die einzige Frau. Also man könnte es auch andersrum machen. Ich bin die einzige neben ihr, weil sie ist natürlich irgendwie in der zweiten Liga deutlich auch bekannter und macht ja jetzt auch vermehrt zum Thema. Sie hat ja auch im Interview gerade vor kurzem gesagt, sie wollte das eigentlich ganz lange nicht zum Thema machen. Und jetzt ist sie gerade an so einem Punkt angekommen, wo sie sagt, sie findet auch, man müsste über eine Quote reden, dass Frauen halt in den Gremien repräsentiert werden, weil es von sich aus offenbar nicht so richtig eine Bewegung dahin gibt, dass Männer das auch selbstverständlich finden und sich darum auch stärker bemühen.
Und wenn du jetzt das Stichwort dann schon bringst, findest du auch, wir müssten über eine Quote reden?
Also ich bin ja auch im Politbetrieb unterwegs, wo ich eine große Verwächterin der Quote bin, weil ich glaube, in dem Moment, wo man beobachten kann, dass es nicht von alleine passiert, muss man nachhelfen. Und sei es halt nur als Brücke, bis das eine Normalität geworden ist. Ich glaube halt wirklich, in den Fußballstadien selber sind Frauen noch nicht im gleichen Maße, in gleicher Anzahl wie Männer präsent. Deswegen wäre vielleicht eine 50-%-Quote da nicht realistisch gerade. Aber ich glaube schon, dass es spannend wäre, darüber nachzudenken, ob man nicht irgendwie mit einer 25-%-Quote anfängt. Also auf die Sicht von Frauen einfach mit einfließt, die Erfahrung, die man als Frau im Fußball macht. Aber natürlich wäre eigentlich eine andere Adresse auch die ganzen Verbände, also die Fußballverbände. Beim DFB, beim NOFV, das sind, also ich kann es jetzt beim DFB, es ist noch wenigstens von einer Altersstruktur ein bisschen durchmischter. Aber in den regionalen Verbänden, also der NOFV, das sind halt nur alte Männer jetzt geführt. Und da glaube ich, wäre es schon eigentlich auch eine Aufgabe, darüber nachzudenken, ob man da nicht Frauen auch stärker in Verantwortung nimmt.
Der DFB, der Verein der Alten Männer. Lass uns mit dem Thema besser nicht anfangen, sonst ist die Zeit nämlich auch vorbei. Jetzt hatten wir ja hier, wir sitzen hier auf einem Fußballfilmfestival, was auch das Thema Frauen im Fußball mit zum Hauptthema gemacht hat in diesem Jahr. Marvin, gestern konnte man einen Film sehen über eine schwedische Frauen-Nationalmannschaft, Frauenmannschaft, nicht die Nationalmannschaft. Es ging um den FC Rosengar. Und da wurde unter anderem thematisiert, der Fußball versucht ja überall zu wachsen, aus dem Hauptantrieb mehr Geld zu generieren. Natürlich, welchen anderen Antrieb sollte es in unserer Welt auch geben? Und da wurde aber die interessante These gemacht, naja, wenn der Fußball wachsen möchte, dann ist eigentlich der Bereich der Frauen der interessantere als der der Männer, weil der schon ganz gut erschlossen ist, wo man ja auch viel dann in so Marketing-Bereiche reinkommt. Also Sponsoren können da ja noch ganz andere Zielgruppen erreichen, als sie sie jetzt erreichen. Wie würdest du denn sagen, im Bereich der jungen digitalen Fans, sind da nennenswert mehr Frauen aktiv? Kann man die anders erreichen? Siehst du da auch Potenziale?
Ich glaube, dass sich junge Fußballfans schon sehr, sehr stark von dem, von quasi jetzt mal unserer Generation unterscheiden. Also auf der einen Seite steile These. Ich weiß. Ich glaube, dass Frauenfußball in der jüngeren Generation einen höheren Stellenwert hat, schon allein, weil es die jüngere Generation eine andere Art hat, Fußball zu konsumieren. Und ich glaube, in einer Zeit, wo Frauenfußball im Fernsehen nicht ansatzweise in der Art präsent ist wie Männerfußball, sind halt digitale Medien, wo ich Spielerinnen direkt folge, wo ich den Teams direkt folge, halten stärkerer Draht, überhaupt den Sport so zu verfolgen. Und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass die Generation und Copa90, die haben einen Report rausgebracht, wo sie sich eben mit jungen Fußballfans beschäftigt haben, die gefragt haben, was sind eure Interessen und da ist Frauenfußball gegenüber einer älteren Generation einfach stark über repräsentiert. Kommt noch nicht an den Männerfußball ran, aber es ist eben eine andere Art und Weise, eine größere Offenheit und ich bin auch der Meinung, eine stärkere Verbundenheit zum Spiel an sich, zum Fußball und nicht zu einem Verein. Ja, wenn ich mir einen jungen Fußballfan anschaue, dann ist, und der Samstagszeit hat Fußball zu gucken, dann ist jetzt weniger die Tagesplanung, okay, 15.30 und ab 15 Uhr schaue ich mir irgendwie den Sky Vorbericht an, ob das zu empfehlen ist, anderes Thema, aber da ist halt eher, okay, irgendwie Manchester City spielt noch gerade gegen Arsenal, das Spiel schaue ich mir an und da hat dann Bayern gegen Mainz eher schlechte Chancen, dann schaue ich mir halt das Premier League-Spiel noch zu Ende an und schalte halt vielleicht in der zweiten Halbzeit erst dazu oder anderes Beispiel, so rund 75 Prozent der jungen Fußballfans wünschen sich eigentlich im Gegensatz zu Sky ein Angebot, wo sie einfach nur für die letzten 20 Minuten im Fußball zahlen würden, das ist vielleicht für viele im Raum eine sehr unromantische Vorstellung, sich nur die letzten 20 Minuten von dem Spiel anzuschauen, aber es ist halt eine andere Art, Fußball zu konsumieren. Genau, es ist halt eine andere Art, Fußball zu konsumieren.
Ja und glaubst du, dass das auch den Fußball verändern wird? Weil das eine ist, dass wir jetzt sagen, Fußballfans konsumieren den Fußball ganz unterschiedlich, das gab es ja vielleicht auch schon immer, aber wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel sagst, 75 Prozent der jungen Fußballfans würden für die letzten 20 Minuten Geld bezahlen oder nur die letzten 20 Minuten zu sehen, das finde ich dann schon wieder einigermaßen irre. Das geht dann schon wieder auch komplett aus meiner Lebensrealität raus. Ich sehe aber vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu viel Fußball, muss man an der Stelle zugestehen. Aber glaubst du, dass das jetzt einfach nur so ein Phänomen ist und Jugendliche haben ja schon immer anders konsumiert als die älteren Generationen oder glaubst du, das könnte auch den Fußball verändern?
Natürlich wird es den Fußball verändern. Also ich glaube, das ist grundsätzlich so, dass ja auch Vereine irgendwie versuchen, wenn die aktuellen Stadiongänge oder die aktuellen Mitglieder älter werden, kommt dann irgendjemand mal auf die Idee, okay, jetzt müssen wir uns irgendwie wieder Richtung jüngere Zielgruppe orientieren und irgendwie aktuell ist ja der sicherste Weg, sich irgendwie mit einer jüngeren Zielgruppe zu identifizieren oder die anzusprechen, irgendwie ein FIFA-E-Sport-Team zu gründen. Das ist so der Schritt, mit dem man aktuell irgendwie wenig falsch machen kann, aus Sicht der Funktionäre.
Aber erreicht man damit wirklich alle? Nein, natürlich nicht.
Also das ist ja eben nicht, also das ist halt der ganz einfache Schritt zu sagen, wir tun ja jetzt auch was für die jüngere Zielgruppe. Wir haben ja jetzt auch ein E-Sports-Team und da sind da Leute, die nicht mehr ins Stadion kommen, können sich jetzt irgendwie auch unsere Spieler auf Twitch angucken. Aber es ist ja nun ganz leichter, homeopathischer Schritt, irgendwie eine jüngere Zielgruppe zu erreichen. Ich glaube, das spannende Räre ist, dass, wie du es auch gerade schon angesprochen hast, jüngere Zielgruppe haben einen anderen Anspruch an den Fußball. Also in jüngeren Zielgruppen ist das Thema, wenn ich mich mit Fußball beschäftige, dann hat der Rassismus keinen Platz, einen anderen Stellenwert, als ich glaube zu sagen im Schnitt in einer älteren Generation.
Wann gibt es das E-Sports-Team von Babelsberg?
Gibt schon, aber da kam es tatsächlich irgendwie aus der Fanszene raus. Also ich glaube, in der vierten Liga, wo man so täglich ums Überleben kämpfen muss, hat man andere Sorgen, als ein E-Sports-Team zu gründen, aber genau da ist es zum Beispiel von Fans gekommen und da waren irgendwie super junge engagierte Leute, die irgendwie jetzt irgendwelche bundesweiten Turniere organisieren. Ich finde es total schräg. Also ich finde es gut. Ich meine, wir haben mittlerweile ganz viele Abteilungen bis hin zum Pferdesport. Insofern, der Galaf hat auch E-Sports seinen Platz, aber wiederum hat er mit meinem Fußballempfinden auch gar nichts zu tun, aber gibt's schon.
Und wenn das jetzt nicht von den Fans selbst initiiert worden wäre, wie wichtig glaubst du, ist es für einen Verein da tatsächlich aktiv zu sein, wenn Marvin jetzt sagt, das hat sich so ein bisschen so wie ein homöopathisches Feigenblatt angehört in der Darstellung von Marvin, um eben für Junge auch was zu tun? Würdest es auch ähnlich charakterisieren?
Ich kann mir das gut vorstellen. Das ist tatsächlich nicht meine Welt, um das richtig einschätzen zu können, aber ich glaube, dass es ein bisschen schwierig ist, sowas aufzuoktruieren. Also sowas gründen zu wollen, um junge Leute anzuziehen, war ja schon auch für junge Leute, also das ist tatsächlich vielleicht dann doch ein Unterschied, aber ich würde mal davon ausgehen, das muss ja Leute geben im eigenen Verein, die sich dafür interessieren. Deswegen käme es mir komisch vor, das sozusagen zu gründen und zu hoffen, dass dadurch Leute zum Verein kommen. Aber wenn es aus dem Verein heraus kommt und Leute darüber auch die Identifikation, die sie mit dem Verein haben, nochmal in eine andere Zielgruppe tragen, ist es natürlich für uns auch gut.
Okay, aber du gehst da mit der These ran, dass Vereine immer Ahnung von denen haben, was sie tun. Und das ist ja schon mal eine steile These.
Ich bin nicht beim HSV.
Schön, dass die HSV-Referenz mal nicht von mir kam im Rasenfunk. Aber das ist jetzt ein anderer Aspekt. Welche Rolle spielen denn dann eSportarten? Also wir sprechen ja nicht nur über Fußballsimulationen wie Fifa19, was nochmal so ein ganz eigenes Nebenthema ist oder über den Fußballmanager 2019. Ich habe inzwischen Hörerinnen und Hörer, wo ich das Gefühl habe, die informieren sich eher darüber, über die Spiele, über die ich spreche, als über andere Medien, in denen man dann den echten Fußball quasi sehen kann, also denen, der physisch auf dem Platz stattfindet. Welche Rolle spielt denn da der eSports? Das ist ja ein unglaublich gehyptes Thema.
Naja, ich glaube, was ganz wichtig ist, also eSports ist nicht Fifa. Also, wenn man sich eSports anguckt, dann ist Fifa ja gerade in die zweite Liga des eSports irgendwie aufgestiegen. Also, wenn wir über eSports reden, dann reden wir über League of Legends, über Dota 2, über Counter-Strike und nicht über Fifa. Das ist, Fifa ist in Deutschland da sehr beliebt und sicherlich auch für einen Fußballverein der logische erste Schritt, um im eSport aktiv zu werden, weil man einfach sagt, wir spielen Fußball auf dem Platz, die Jungs an der Konsole spielen virtuellen Fußball, hey, it's a match. Und die einzigen, die da wirklich an einen konsequenten Schritt gegangen sind und gesagt haben, wenn wir jetzt hier eine eSports-Abteilung aufbauen, dann müssen wir auch in so einen tatsächlich relevanten Titel gehen, ist dann tatsächlich Schalke 04, die ihr eigenes League of Legends-Team haben, die es nicht in die Playoffs geschafft haben, also in den Profis, der Profi-Abteilung aktuell sportlich, da im Nichts nahe stehen.
Sie sind in ihrem ersten Jahr nach Gründung abgestiegen.
Korrekt, dann aber auch wieder aufgestiegen, also das gibt Hoffnung, den Königsblauen.
Was mich halt bei diesen jungen Fans interessieren würde, ist, weil ich glaube, du hast ja am Anfang dieses Bild gezeichnet mit den Anstoßzeiten und Kommerz und dass wir das alles nicht wollen und da habe ich jetzt wirklich die Frage, ob das für junge Leute noch so ein Thema ist. Also ob nicht Kommerz so normal ist, dass man es einfach hinnimmt und ich meine, es gibt dann vielleicht über so Politisierung manchmal dann eben Konflikte darum, wer jetzt der Sponsor wird und wie präsent er ist und da merke ich schon, dass das ein Thema wird, aber grundsätzlich, dass es Kommerzumsteuern gibt, ist glaube ich total Normalität und auch die Frage von Anstoßzeiten spielt wahrscheinlich für junge Leute nicht mehr so die Rolle, weil sie sich das eh ganz anders konsumieren und da hätte ich jetzt auch das Gefühl, also das Bild, was du zeichnest, ist auch in meiner Generation zum Beispiel nicht mehr, wir sind ja eine Generation, aber auch da ist es schon brüchig, also da gibt es auch nicht mehr so diese Identifikation mit Sportschau und alle müssen gleichzeitig anstoßen, sondern fast eher bei Leuten, die sich für Fußball interessieren, die insgeheim eigentlich ganz gut finden, dass es so viele Anstoßzeiten gibt, wo sie halt, wenn sie Samstagnachmittag nicht können, auch Sonntag noch ein Spiel gucken können und das erst dann, wenn es wirklich ins Absurde kippt, Also wenn man irgendwie so Montagabend oder wo man als Fan dann halt nicht mehr anreisen kann zu Auswärtsspielen, dann wird es glaube ich ein Thema. Aber so dieses ganz enge Bild, glaube ich, das gibt es so nicht mehr und das wird wahrscheinlich unter den jungen Leuten halt noch krasser sein.
Du hast ja gerade gefragt, was ist die Rolle von Fußball im E-Sport? Ich finde eigentlich auch die Gegenperspektive ganz spannend. Also was ist die Rolle von E-Sport, von Gaming im Fußball? Also ich glaube wir waren alle gewissermaßen genervt von Spielern, sei es Timo Werner oder Antoine Griezmann im WM-Finale, wenn es darum geht, einen Fortnite-Jubel zu zelebrieren. Aber das ist ja nun mal eigentlich auch was Spannendes aus der Perspektive heraus. Auch die jungen Spieler werden ja mit Gaming in einer anderen Weise sozialisiert, als es ältere sind. Und plötzlich findet da quasi Gaming, E-Sport, Fortnite, E-Sport, anderes Thema, also Gaming, E-Sport, die Unterscheidung, aber... Also E-Sport ist ja kompetitives Gaming und Gaming generell kann von Candy Crush bis Fifa19-Spielen auch alles sein. Aber auch die Frage, wo kommt E-Sport in den Fußball? Also Jubel ist jetzt der Jubel ist irgendwie so das eine, aber ich finde es krass, dass es irgendwie einen Einfluss hat, weil es zeigt, dass die Spieler auch ein Teil davon sind und dass dann eben auch auf dem Fußballplatz stattfindet.
Ja, der berühmte Call of Duty-Rücken von Mesut Özil. Das war eine der Erklärungen von Arsenal-Fans, als er nicht gespielt hat, dass er unter anderem deswegen nicht fit wäre, weil er am Tag so viel Call of Duty spielen würde.
Das war ja auch die Diskussion im Sommer, inwiefern da das WLAN im DFB-Mannschaftshotel abgestellt werden musste, weil dann auch bis in die Nacht Fortnite gespielt hat.
Genau, und dann sind wir ja eigentlich in dem Bereich, und das hatten wir ja aber auch irgendwie schon immer. Letztlich ist das ja ein popkulturelles Phänomen, dass sein Weg irgendwie in den Fußball findet. Und es gab schon immer bescheuerte Torjubel, und es gab schon immer Torjubel, die man nachvollziehen konnte. Und man kann sich ja auch sehr darüber amüsieren, wenn dann irgendwelche NBA-Spieler nachgemacht werden. Also Serge Napri musste jetzt neulich wieder erklären, dass sein Torjubel von James Harden aus der NBA kommt. Ich dachte irgendwie, das hätten wir vor zwei Jahren geklärt, aber da haben irgendwie nicht alle das Memo bekommen. Also das hatten wir ja schon immer. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber so, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf kicker.de gehe, dann finde ich manchmal sogar noch vor Frauenfußballergebnissen den E-Sport-Bereich, in dem dann gesagt wird, Fifa19 hat jetzt die Werte der Top-10-Spieler bekannt gegeben, und darunter findet dann eine Diskussion statt, die in dieser Heftigkeit vielleicht hier im Raum eher geführt würde, wenn wir über den DFB sprechen. Also ist ja die Frage, welche Rolle es spielt, zum Teil auch schon beantwortet. Also in den Medien wird es sehr prominent transportiert.
Ich glaube auch von den Spielern selber. Also das mag auch ein leicht selbstdarstellerisches Phänomen sein, da zu diskutieren, ob man wirklich eine 76 in Sprintfähigkeit in Fifa verdient hat, oder doch eher eine 80. Aber das ist ja tatsächlich ein Thema, über das gesprochen wird. Also wenn die Fifa-Werte rauskommen, dann gehen die Tweets viral, wo sich irgendwelche Spieler darüber eschophieren, dass sie in Fifa irgendwie falsch abgebildet werden. Und das kann ja ganz absurde Züge nehmen. Also Samba ist ja irgendwie so das Paradebeispiel, wenn es darum geht, wie irgendwie virtuelle Welt und tatsächlich die Fußballwelt aufeinandertreffen, der ja zeitlang, also immer ein sehr, sehr großes Talent im Fußballmanager war, als er damals noch bei Millwall gespielt hat, und eigentlich jedem Fan vor allem aus dem Fußballmanager präsent war. Und halt immer, damit Zeit seiner Karriere damit verglichen wurde, und so unter Motto, tatsächlich auf der Tribüne, also im Fußballmanager performte er aber besser. Und tatsächlich auch in Interviews darauf angesprochen wurde, und jetzt, wo er seine Karriere beendet hat, da mal ein ganz spannendes, längeres BBC-Interview zugeführt hat, wo er gesagt hat, ja, ich bin halt Zeit, oder die ganze Zeit bin ich damit verglichen worden, wie habe ich mich im Fußballmanager entwickelt, und wie habe ich mich auf dem Platz entwickelt. Die Leute waren enttäuscht, dass ich mich nicht so, wie in dieser Simulation entwickelt habe. Und das finde ich eigentlich verrückt, dass überhaupt so ein Vergleich gezogen wird.
Das ist völlig irre.
Aber wir wissen ja auch, der ein oder andere scoutet nicht nur, wer gegen die Bayern in der Champions League trifft, was den neuen Stürmer angeht, sondern auch im Fußballmanager. Das hat halt schon so eine gewisse Berechtigung, oder nee, Berechtigung ist der falsche Begriff, aber es ist schon spannend zu sehen, dass sich Spieler, die habe ich im Fußballmanager vor zehn Jahren, waren die irgendwie 16, die haben sich ähnlich entwickelt wie in dieser Simulation. Das ist, glaube ich, schon spannend, das irgendwie auch als Prognosetool zu nutzen. Aber wenn es dann so weit geht, dass ich einem realen Spieler sage, also so toll wie am PC, hast du dich nicht entwickelt, das ist schon irgendwie leicht fragwürdig.
Ja, wenn du mal von einem NFL-Profi aufs Maul gekommen wolltest, dann sagt er eben, du hast mir die Fantasy-Liga verloren, das haben die da drauf angesprochen zu werden. Also das sage ich jetzt nicht aus persönlicher Erfahrung, das habe ich mitbekommen. Ich bin ja nicht bescheuert, ne? Jetzt reden wir ja dann über ganz verschiedene Arten, wie man Fußball konsumiert und ich stelle mir die Frage, Katharina, welche Rolle spielt eigentlich da noch der Stadionbesuch? Jetzt auch aus deiner persönlichen Erfahrung, die ihr bei Babelsberg macht. Gehen junge Menschen noch ins Stadion? Haben die da überhaupt Bock drauf? Einfacher ist ja von zu Hause aus.
Jetzt haben wir das große Glück, dass unsere Spiele nicht im Fernsehen übertragen werden. Aber tatsächlich ist das ein Problem, weil ich glaube auch, dass viele junge Leute, also es kann Stärke und Schwäche sein, natürlich so ein Verein wie Babelsberg zu haben, wo viele junge Leute eben auch hingehen, weil das politische Engagement für sie eine Rolle spielt und wo sie merken, das ist auch ein Ort, wo sie dem auch nachgehen können, wo sie auch zeigen können, was, und da kommt es ja ganz nah an diesen Fußballkulturbegriff, dass es nicht nur um Fußball geht. Aber wir haben natürlich dauernd auch die Debatten, gerade von den Älteren, die ja sagen, das hat ja mit Fußball nichts mehr zu tun. Wo ich mal denke, ja, aber da kommen sozusagen verschiedene Identitäten, greifen da ineinander und man kann sich auch manchmal froh schätzen, wenn man sieht, wie die Mannschaft dann mal mehrere Spiele nacheinander verliert, dass man auch noch andere Identifikationspunkte hat, weshalb Leute ins Stadion kommen. Ich für mich persönlich, ich bin ja damit groß geworden mit dem Stadionbesuch. Also das ist ja, wenn auch mal ganz persönlich antworten würde, was Fußballkultur gehört bei mir dazu, dass wir spielen immer, in der Regel fast immer sonntags, sodass es gerade noch morgens für einen Kaffee reicht, wenn man dann ins Stadion fährt oder eben Freitagabend mit Flutlicht. Das kriegst du natürlich irgendwie am Bildschirm nicht. Also dieses Erlebnis, wenn du dann die Straße runterläufst Richtung Stadion und siehst von Weitem schon die Flutlichtmasten strahlen, das ist natürlich, jedes Mal denke ich wieder, ach, was für ein toller Kiezverein. Obwohl ich selber gar nicht aus dem Kiez komme, sondern ja schon seit zehn Jahren in Berlin wohne, aber da verbindet sich ganz viel, was ich auch meinte, mit dem, was sich gesellschaftlich so abbildet, wer da so hinströmt, wie unterschiedlich die Menschen sind, die sich aber alle für das eine interessieren. Und ich glaube, das kannst du nicht ersetzen. Also das ist ein anderes Fußballgefühl, als das, was vielleicht junge Leute haben, die sich nur noch oder mit einem ganz anderen Fußballkonsum konfrontiert sind oder aufgewachsen sind.
Und warum glaubst du, dass sich dann so viele Vereine genau diesen Themen verwehren? Also eben der Tatsache, dass sich die Gesellschaft in einem guten Querschnitt im Stadion trifft und damit dann da auch logischerweise gesellschaftliche, schrägstrich politische Themen eine Rolle spielen müssen, zwangsläufig. Na, die gute alte These unter anderem von Rasenballsport Leipzig transportiert, wobei die jetzt natürlich nicht vielleicht das beste Beispiel sind, weil es auch nicht der repräsentative Verein ist, in Klammern zum Glück aus der Sicht vieler. Dass sie sagen, Fußball und Politik sind zwei getrennte Dinge. Politik hat im Stadion nichts zu suchen. Wir möchten das gerne voneinander trennen.
Also ich meine, in der Regionalliga ist es eindeutig, da gibt es natürlich, also gerade in der Regionalliga Nordost, wahnsinnig viele Vereine, die ein massives Problem mit Nazis in den Stadien haben. Und da, glaube ich, spielt natürlich eine Rolle auch, dass man sich damit nicht auseinandersetzen will oder sich auch machtlos zeigt. Also ich meine, der Fall jetzt, Chemnitzer FC, ist glaube ich auch, da gibt es da einfach Funktionäre, die sich auch ausgeliefert fühlen. Die wissen, dass es für sie auch ganz existenziell und persönlich werden kann, wenn sie das als ein Thema aufmachen würde. Also ich ziehe da meinen Hut vor den Spielern, die jetzt diesen offenen Brief gemacht haben, wo sie sagen, also wir sind, ich weiß gar nicht, was sie, himmelblau, bunt, auf jeden Fall nicht braun. Weil das natürlich in Konfrontation mit so einer Fanszene, also da gab es, ich habe jetzt viele Gerüchte gehört, wie da die Spieler unter Druck gesetzt wurden, sich an dieser Trauerbekundung im Stadion zu beteiligen. Das ist für die existenziell, sich mit ihrem eigenen Publikum anzulegen. Ich glaube, da ist es auch so ein bisschen Selbstschutz, zu sagen, wir versuchen das Politik-Thema draußen zu halten, weil wir sonst ein Problem mit den eigenen Fans bekommen würden.
Interessante Perspektive, vor allem, wenn man in die unteren Ligen geht, ist es natürlich sicherlich ein Aspekt, der nicht zu vernachlässigen ist. Und dann zurückzukommen zu der Frage, was machen wir jetzt dann mit unserem fußballkulturellen Begriff, so schwammig er wahrscheinlich bei jedem hier selbst formuliert ist. Aber wenn du jetzt sagen würdest, Katharina, so zwei, drei Themen, bei denen du das Gefühl hast, die müssen mehr eine Rolle spielen, wenn wir über Fußballkultur sprechen. Was kommt dir da als erstes in den Sinn?
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen aus meiner Erfahrung bei uns im Stadion. Das, was mich sehr umtreibt, ist schon, dass ich aus so einer Perspektive komme von Fußball als proletarischer Sport. Und das natürlich alles, was sich kulturell im Stadion verändert, also auch sozusagen im total positiven Sinne von Diskriminierung ist ein Thema, wird zurückgedrängt. Also gegen Rassismus, Homophobie oder auch Frauenfeindlichkeit wird vorgegangen, dass du aber natürlich immer auch aufpassen musst, dass du da durch den Querschnitt der Gesellschaft auch Leute hast, die vielleicht mit diesen Themen nicht so einen reflektierten Umgang haben und was ich immer vermeiden wollen würde, ist so eine Stimmung von, du hast einen dummen Spruch gemacht, du hast dir nichts zu suchen, sondern das auch Stadion ein Ort ist von Lehr- und Lernprozess, also dass man auch gegenseitig sich aufmerksam macht auf Dinge, die man anders machen will, die aber nicht dazu führen, dass Leute verdrängt werden. Also ich meine, in höheren Ligen ist Verdrängung eher über Eintrittspreise ein Thema. Das ist jetzt bei uns, also ich würde sagen, es ist natürlich auch in unteren Ligen, auch 10 Euro in unteren Ligen sind für manche Leute viel Geld. Aber es ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so vorderrangig, sondern da ist es glaube ich total wichtig, dass du, wenn du ein bestimmtes subkulturelles Milieu abbildest, dass das nicht so dominant wird, dass andere sich da nicht mehr zu Hause fühlen. Also ich habe, und da glaube ich, es gibt jetzt wieder zufällig ein gutes Beispiel für dieses Frauenthema, wie man da wahrgenommen wird. Ich sitze ja nun seit ein paar Jahren, seit ich im Aufsichtsrat bin, ich stehe nicht mehr in der Kurve, also nur bei Auswärtsspielen, weil da will ich dann nicht auf der Heimtribüne sitzen, aber jetzt sitze ich natürlich irgendwie in diesem WIP-Bereich, der bei Babelsberg, kann man sich das WIP-Bereich anders als woanders vorstellen, ja, ist halt ein Dach drüber, und man sitzt. Und da hatte ich eigentlich ein ganz niedliches Erlebnis, dass da waren so zwei Cousins von unserem Mittelfeldspieler, ein kroatischer Spieler, und die zwei Cousins, wirklich kann man so vorstellen, so dicke kroatische Jungs, die da die ganze Zeit Kette rauchen, und da hat er irgendwann den Schiri-Beleidigern gesagt, der pfeift wie eine Frau, und da habe ich gesagt, Kollege, ich meine, ich bin ab einer hoher Teureranzschwelle, was so Beleidigungen von Schiris angeht, da bin ich jetzt nicht zimperlich, aber du sollst dich nicht als Frau beleidigen, weil das ist ja eine Beleidigung auch gegen mich, also ihr macht irgendwas schlecht, also macht da irgendwas wie eine Frau, das ist doch, da hat er lange geguckt, meinte so, das habe ich so noch nie gesehen, ja, du hast eigentlich total recht, das mache ich jetzt nicht mehr. Das war dann irgendwie niedlich, und das meine ich mit so, das ist so ein Prozess, wo man voneinander lernen muss, und die falsche Antwort wäre zu sagen, ey, du bist ein dummer Rassist, verlass das Stadion. Und das glaube ich, da muss man einen guten Grad finden, dass man annimmt, dass Fußballkultur sich verändert durch solche Auseinandersetzungen, dass Diskriminierung zurückgedrängt wird, oder auch so ein chauvinistisches Verhalten, und das aber nicht umschlägt in so eine Belehrung, von hier müssen sich alle korrekt verhalten und du gehörst nicht dazu.
Was aber ja eine irre schwierige Herausforderung ist.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Gut, und jetzt reden wir immer sehr viel über den Stadionbesuch. Und Marvin, wenn wir jetzt über junge Fans sprechen, dann haben wir ja vorhin schon mal so angerissen, da geht es dann viel um anderen Konsum von Fußball. Was glaubst du, sind denn da die wirklich relevanten Themen? Jetzt jenseits von Gimmicks, wie eben wir machen eine E-Sports-Anteilung auf, weil wir glauben, damit würden wir den jungen Fans schon gerecht werden. Was glaubst du, sind da so Faktoren, die auch wirklich relevant sein werden, auch noch in zwei bis fünf Jahren?
Um noch mal kurz auf das Thema Steilung-Besuch zurückzukommen, ich glaube, was ganz spannend ist, ist, dass junge Leute eher zum Amateur-Fußball gehen als zum Profifußball. Also das ist in Deutschland jetzt schon so, in Großbritannien entwickelt sich das gerade noch viel dynamischer, weil wenn ich mir angucke, weil Manchester United, Arsenal oder Liverpool kostet irgendwie die günstigste Dauerkarte für einen Jugendlichen, irgendwas zwischen 600 und 1000 Euro. Das ist halt, da wird halt eine junge Generation komplett aus dem Stadion rausgepreist. Das heißt also, wenn wir auch über, wie sich Fußballkultur entwickelt, dann werden wir nicht da und quasi die Entwicklung, die wir in Großbritannien sehen, in England sehen, auch in Deutschland ihren Lauf nimmt, dann werden wir nicht darum rumkommen, dass wir Fußballkultur nicht mehr nur noch auf Basis der Themen definieren können, die wir irgendwie im Fußballstadion wahrnehmen. Und du hast gefragt, was ist relevant für Jugendliche? Also ich finde es ganz spannend, wenn man sich den Medienkonsum anguckt, Bayern München hat auf YouTube 250 Millionen Views, die Freekicker sind 2 Milliarden. So kurz wie die Freekicker sind? Die Freekicker sind junge Menschen, die digital affin sind, die Fußballschuhe testen und auch sonst grundsätzlich sich mit Fußball auf einem ganz anderen Level beschäftigen. Das ist für junge Fußballfans das Review zum neuen, schlag mich tot, Copa 19.1, genauso relevant wie für uns vielleicht von einem deutschen Hersteller. Da ist aber das Review über diesen Schuh und ob man damit besonders gut Nackeschotze schießen kann, ähnlich relevant wie für uns zu sehen, wie die SGE ihre Europapokalkurio vorbereitet hat. Das ist eine andere Art von Fußballkonsum, sich mit der Sportart Fußball auseinanderzusetzen. Das geht sehr stark weg von den 90 Minuten, die auf dem Platz sind, hin zu digitalen Medien. Dann folge ich einem Spieler auf Instagram, weil ich seine persönliche Seite sehen will. Es ist dann auch die Frage, bei wem das gerechtfertigt ist und bei wem man merkt, da sitzt eine Agentur auf einem Account von sieben Personen. Das fällt einem nicht erst auf, wenn da Spielerprofile auch verwechselt werden. Das ist eine andere Art und wenn diese Leute sich mit Fußball beschäftigen, dann sind es halt Bleacher Report oder Copa90, wo die Leute sich halt abgeholt fühlen. Da ist es dann nicht mehr der Kicker-Artikel, der zu einem Spiel gelesen wird. Das ist eine andere Art, Fußball zu konsumieren und auch ein Spiel auf ein Meme zu reduzieren.
Na ja, mir fehlt halt, dass er sagt, dass junge Fußballfans gerne Podcasts hören würden. Ab dann hätte ich wieder Hoffnung. Ich würde sagen, an der Stelle können wir jetzt mal die Diskussion für Fragen öffnen, vor allem weil ich schon erfreulicherweise den ersten Finger in der Luft sehe. Wir würden es so machen, komm bitte nach vorne, du bekommst dieses Mikro, was ich jetzt gerade noch habe, und wir teilen uns dann einfach zwei.
Ich bin Jan Grubi, Union-Fan, und Sympathien für Babelsberg habe ich auch grundsätzlich, für Bayern nicht, tut mir leid Max. Mir fällt oft, dass ihr, ich hoffe ihr versteht mich, wenn ich Berliner bin, mir fällt oft, dass ihr ganz viel über E-Sports und über wie man Fans, oder junge Fans, in Stadion holt, spricht. Ich glaube, das liegt vor allem im Stehplatzbereich. Der wird immer werter abgeschafft und wenn du zum Beispiel in die Allianz-Arena kommst, dann hast du im Prinzip einen Friedhof, bis auf da so eine kleine Tribüne, wo die richtig Rambazamba machen, aber ansonsten ist Ruhe. Die sitzen alle da, manche haben weiße T-Shirts an und bilden Tee, und da manche Punkte, aber im Prinzip ist Ruhe. Und wenn du Leute mitnimmst, also ich hab meine Frau zum Beispiel, die hab ich mitgenommen 2012 zur Union, weil sie gefragt hat, was machst du denn am Freitag? Ich hab gesagt, ich geh zur Union, komm ich mal mit, kieke mir mal an. Haben wir uns das Spiel angekickt, war langweilig, war ein einzigen Gräuter für. Und dann sind wir rausgehangen und dann sagst du, war das geil. Und seitdem kriegst du nicht mehr los. Und das ist, weil wir gestanden haben, weil man seine Emotionen beim Stehen rausbringen kann. Das ist in der Ostkurve auch so. Ich hab auch Arbeitskollegen, da gehen die jungen Töchter in die Ostkurve und die freuen sich darüber. Die sind richtig Ultras geworden, weil sie da stehen können. Im Olympiastand ist sonst wenig Platz dafür, aber da ist wirklich auch genauso. Ich glaube, dieser Stehplatzbereich, oder wenn du bei San Pauli siehst, wie viele junge Leute da im Prinzip bei den Ultras mitmachen, Stehplätze sind ganz, ganz wichtig. Und die Krux ist, das hast du ja schon richtig gesagt, in England gibt es eine Jugendkultur im Fußball gar nicht mehr, gibt es auch keine Stehplätze mehr. Also ich glaube, da liegt viel dran.
Da Bayern angesprochen wurde, habe ich das Gefühl, ich muss jetzt reagieren. Sehr wichtiger Punkt, eine Anmerkung dazu, aber ich möchte nicht widersprechen, aber kurz ein etwas aus meiner Lebensrealität spiegeln. Ich stehe ja immer so, also ich stehe ja so auf einem ganz komischen Dreieck zwischen Fan-Kultur, zwischen Journalisten-Perspektive und zwischen ganz dreckig Vereinsperspektive, Sportmarketing, Commerz ohne Ende. Und da ist die Sache, dass man tatsächlich dieses Gehen in den Stehplatzbereich, es gibt die Fans, für die das absolut wichtig ist und es ist auch ein komplett anderes Stadion-Erlebnis, wenn ich es mir raussuchen kann, stehe ich immer. Das ist für mich auch Fußball, ehrlich gesagt, würde dann auch nicht kalt. Ich verstehe nicht, warum die Leute sich hinsetzen, und dann beschweren sie sich, dass es kalt war und geregnet hat. Ja, dann bewegt euch doch einfach. Aber das Interessante ist, dass man da ganz schnell auch an ein Ende kommt, an ein Ende derjenigen, für die das wichtig ist. Es gibt diejenigen Fans, für die das das Stadion-Erlebnis ausmacht. Wenn wir aber zum Beispiel über Themen sprechen, das war bei den Bayern ein Thema, als sie LEDs eingeführt haben. Und dann konnten sie auf einmal ganz tolle Lichteffekte machen bei der Ausstellung und auch bei Toren. Und fürchterlich nervig. Und dann habe ich mich erst mit Leuten aus der Südkurve drüber unterhalten und alle, boah, das ist fürchterlich so ein Scheiß. Und ja, auch Transbis hochgehalten, dass das alles doof ist. Dann habe ich mich mit Journalisten drüber unterhalten, denen war es völlig egal. Die hatten das zum Teil gar nicht so wirklich mitbekommen, weil sie eh nur ihren Live-Ticker geschrieben hatten. Und dann habe ich mich mit Leuten vom Verein drüber unterhalten. Und die haben mir dann gespiegelt, überwältigende Reaktionen. Riesenbegeisterung, das wäre nochmal richtig cool. Man könnte jetzt richtig von der Stimmung her noch mal eins drauflegen. Sie haben das Wort Stimmung verwendet. Weil der Fußball, der Stadionbesuch, für einen großen Teil der Menschen auch durch so passiverlebbare Eventisierung belebt werden kann. Also es gibt die Fans, die machen sich ihre Stimmung selbst. Und ich glaube, es gibt aber auch einen nicht zu vernachlässigen Anteil von Stadionbesuchern, die wollen eventisiert werden. Also die wollen quasi die Stimmung präsentiert werden. Und wenn dann dazu... Ja, ich glaube, da sind aber auch junge Leute mit dabei. Also die Anmerkung war, dass ich ja noch jungen Leuten gefahrtete.
Genau, ich habe nur gerade auch an meinen einzigen Stadionbesuch bei RB Leipzig denken müssen. Als du von Event gesprochen hast, weil ich glaube, dass es auch gerade bei den jungen Leuten viele gibt, die es gar nicht mehr anders kennen. Also ich glaube auch, wenn du natürlich in so eine Stehplatzkultur reinkommst, dann ist das ganz wesentlich. Aber es gibt ja auch wahnsinnig viele, die irgendwie mit den Eltern ins Stadion gehen. Und ich fand das wirklich bei RB... Da gab es in dem Blog, wo ich saß, ich habe mit sagen lassen, es gibt eigentlich keine Klatschpoppen bei denen, aber an dem Tag gab es welche. Und es gibt ja auch diesen Stadionsprecher, der da nicht nur der Sprecher ist, sondern auch den Vortänzer macht. Also jeden Namen, den er aufruft, den tanzt er auch irgendwie so ein bisschen Waldorf-mäßig. Das ist ja irgendwie auch eine, wenn ich das gar nicht anders kenne, ist das natürlich irgendwie eine Form von Event, die junge Leute vielleicht auch mitmachen, feiern, keine Ahnung. Also das ist ja auch die Frage, gerade bei den jungen Leuten, wie sie es teilweise kennengelernt haben. Und ich glaube auch, da war halt, wenn du vor 20 Jahren Stadion gegangen bist, gab es das noch nicht so. Da war das nicht Teil von Fußballkultur. Aber heute ist es wahrscheinlich auch Teil von Fußballkultur.
Also wo wir auf dem Thema traumatisierendes Stadion-Erlebnis gerade sind. Ich war am Mittwoch in Wolfsburg, weil mich nämlich ein guter Freund, der die Nationalmannschaft Fotografie zum Spiel eingeladen hat. Und also da kann ich keinem empfehlen, sein Kind mit so einem DFB-Länderspiel zu nehmen, um es in Sachen Fußballkultur oder Stadion-Erlebnis zu prägen. Also das ist halt, ich glaube man hat das auch auf Twitter ganz gut mitgekriegt. Ich habe mir das nachher ein bisschen durchgelesen und gedacht, das Lauteste im Stadion, wenn man es am Fernseher konsumiert hat, waren wahrscheinlich die Verschlüsse der Sportfotografen, die einen da doch arg gestört haben. Es war komplett still. Und wenn ich mir überlege, da werden halt viele kleine Kinder mit ins Stadion genommen und das ist dann der erste Eindruck, so ist Fußball im Stadion. Also dann kann ich es mir auch tatsächlich digital anschauen, wenn das mein erster Eindruck ist von Fußballerlebnis im Stadion. Also geht mit euren Kindern zum ersten Mal, woanders.
Wir haben noch eine Wortmeldung, es ist Sport hier.
Hallo, ich bin Klaus, ich bin Hertha-Fan. Ich weiß, die Selbsthilfegruppe habe ich schon gegründet. Die gibt es schon zehn Jahre, als WhatsApp-Gruppe. Ich glaube, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Das war es schon immer so. Es gibt Leute, die das in der Familie mitgekriegt haben. Es gibt Generationen und was man gerne vergisst, wir reden jetzt hier über Union vielleicht, auch über Hertha. Du kannst hier in Berlin mit der U-Bahn, mit der S-Bahn und mit der Straßenbahn zum Spiel fahren. Mein Kleiner, wir haben uns getrennt, der wohnt jetzt zwischen Siegen, das ist zwischen Frankfurt und zwischen Köln, am Arsch der Welt. Da gibt es eine Fußballfamilie, die spielen da bei Fortuna Freudenberg, der 12-jährige mittlerweile bei Köln in der Jugend. Die 12-jährige wollte auch, sollte auch zu Köln, die hat keinen Bock. Aber diese ganze Familie, vollkommen Fußballverrückt, konsumiert Fußball komplett anders auf dem Land. Die gehen nicht ins Stadion, weil die können nicht. Die machen das anders, die machen das mit Twitter, die stehen wirklich am Fußballplatz, gucken sich irgendwie die Videos an und machen die Tricks nach. Also es gibt tatsächlich ganz verschiedene Arten, das heutzutage zu konsumieren. Und tatsächlich wahrscheinlich ist Berlin und auch alle Großstädte da ein ganz anderer Punkt als die Leute, die auf dem Land wohnen. Da muss man sich klar darüber sein. Also es gibt eine bestimmte Art von Kommerzialisierung, die kannst du nur über die Medien erreichen. Das ist einfach so. Und ich glaube, dass die ins Stadion kommen, das wird auf Dauer schwierig werden. Ganz ehrlich, die sind damit groß geworden. Also diese YouTube-Dinger, die Kanäle, die du da irgendwie genannt hast, der kennt die wahrscheinlich alle auswendig, der Zwölfjährige. Ganz sicher, also die Diskussion über die Spur. Ich stehe da immer daneben, ich verstehe kein Wort. Echt ehrlich, die sind zwölf. Super Fußballer, also die nehme ich immer aus ohne Ende. Aber du verstehst kein Wort, du hast keinen Bezug zu dieser Art und Weise, wie die Fußball spielen oder leben. Fußball leben. Das ist einfach so. Und vielleicht muss man da mal nachdenken, wie schafft man es tatsächlich, dann irgendwie eben so eine Leute reinzukriegen. Und das ist halt echt schwierig. Ich glaube, da ist eine Generation tatsächlich an den Medien gehangen. Also da sehe ich ein bisschen schwarz.
Ich glaube, das ist so eine Generation, die sich weniger halt an einen Verein bindet. Also ich habe das mit dem Beispiel, okay, schaue ich jetzt samstags Premier League. Ich schaue mir halt samstags, wenn ich bin Fußball interessiert, und schaue mir halt den Fußball an, schaue mir an, was gerade läuft und entscheide mich für das für mich relevanteste Spiel. Natürlich gibt es, es wird immer auch diejenigen geben, die mit einem Verein stark verbunden sind, aber es ist halt einfach eine wachsende Zahl an Leuten, die den Fußball leben und die nicht unbedingt Borussia Dortmund oder Schalke 04 lieben und deswegen Fußball konsumieren.
Aber ich meine, das kenne ich ja sogar aus der eigenen Generation, dass es da so ein bisschen Umschwung gibt. Und das hat aber dann wiederum wahrscheinlich auch damit zu tun, dass einfach die Ligen mitunter so langweilig geworden sind, dass es nicht mehr entscheidend ist, jede Woche halb Bundesliga zu gucken, weil man eh weiß, wer Meister wird, sondern dass man auch irgendwie einfach guckt, ich will attraktiven Fußball sehen und dann schaue ich mir halt ein anderes Spiel an. Und gehe halt vielleicht auch nicht zu Babelsbeck ins Stadion.
Was vielleicht auch anders ist, also wenn man jetzt mal einen Blick in die USA wirft und jetzt ist irgendwie die Major League Soccer für mich noch die Liga. Da geht halt Bastian Schweinsteiger auf seine letzten guten Tage hin und Ray Nourney lässt da auch noch mal irgendwie seine Karriere ausklingen. Aber was da relativ spannend ist, da entwickelt sich eine Fußballkultur auf einem ganz neuen Fundament. Also nicht auf einer Art und Weise, wie schon seit Jahrzehnten Fußball irgendwie im Stadion konsumiert wurde. Und ich habe dann ein Interview mit einem Fan gesehen, der gesagt hat, ich bin halt als New York Fan, bin ich nach Portland gereist. Und die Leute da haben gesagt, ey, hammer, dass du dir den weiten Weg von New York nach Portland machst. Willkommen hier in Portland. Hier hast du ein Bier. Wir gehen zum Stadion. Also zum Beispiel dieses Thema, das Fan-Gruppen miteinander rivalisieren, ist da gar nicht so präsent. Und jetzt hat das natürlich alles seinen Charme. Also ich will gar nicht irgendwie ein gutes Stadtderby in Frage stellen. Aber grundsätzlich, dass dieses Element, die gegen uns da gar nicht so präsent ist, führt halt zu einer anderen Art von Fußballkultur. Und ja, ich bin mal gespannt, wie sich das bei uns entwickelt. Ich wollte dich nicht weiter warten lassen.
Alles gut, ganz entspannt. Hi, ich bin der Noah. Ich bin eigentlich Fan des VfB Stuttgarts. Ich sage aber immer, ich bin in erster Linie Fußballfan. Ich fände es ganz interessant, dass du Wolfsburg eben angesprochen hast. Ich weiß nicht, ob das euch oder so auch aufgefallen ist. Also die Bandenwerbung war doch da noch mal krass stärker als in den Spielen davor. Ist mir zumindest aufgefallen bei diesem Länderspiel. Das hat mich wahnsinnig abgelenkt von dem, was eigentlich für mich wichtig ist. Nämlich das, was auf dem Platz passiert. Und in dem Dilemma befinde ich mich persönlich als jemand, der, sage ich mal, in erster Linie den Sport liebt. Weniger den Verein, weil er ja momentan auch nicht so gut Fußball spielt einfach. Aber das ist immer einfach das Dilemma, dass ich, keine Ahnung, vielleicht Tobias Escherleik so ein bisschen denke, okay, ich will guten, ansehnlichen Fußball sehen. Ich habe ein Bedürfnis danach, ein tolles Spiel zu sehen. Und man merkt einfach, finde ich, dass natürlich mehr und mehr die besten Spieler leider eben in so Ligen wie der Premier League und, was weiß ich, La Liga spielen. Und ich dann immer denke, okay, eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock darauf, das alles zu unterstützen, wie, keine Ahnung, eine Mannschaft wie Man City spielt oder so. Ich will das alles gar nicht, aber ich denke mir dann immer mal wieder, Wahnsinn, wie die kicken, also Wahnsinn, wie die spielen können. Und ich glaube, das ist so mein persönliches Dilemma, ich weiß nicht, ob es anderen Leuten auch so geht, dass ich ein wahnsinniges Bedürfnis habe nach gutem, erstklassigen Fußball, der technisch super ist und den gerne beim VfB Stuttgart sehen würde. Aber, danke. Also da einfach, dass man das so schwer aufhalten kann, weil man denkt, okay, fuck, ich will einfach guten Fußball sehen und das ist so schwierig im Heimatverein.
Da finde ich jetzt wirklich interessant, ob das ein Generationsding ist, weil das ist mir völlig fremd. Es liegt jetzt nicht nur daran, dass ich in der Regionalliga unterwegs bin, aber da habe ich halt, ich kenne es aus anderen Sportern, ich bin zum Beispiel großer Tennis-Fan, da kann ich mir auch alles Mögliche angucken. Beim Fußball habe ich halt schon eine starke Vereinsidentifikation. Also da, ich muss keine erstklassigen Matches sehen, sondern da weiß ich, für wen mein Herz schlägt. Und dann kann ich das mit derselben Inbrunst gucken, wenn die Scheiße kicken, weil am Ende machen sie das Tor. Das wäre interessant in der weiteren Diskussion, auch noch von anderen Beispielen, ob das eine Generationsfrage ist, dass jüngere Leute eher den Fußball sehen wollen und dann auch ein schönes Spiel sehen wollen und so ein Gekloppe sich gar nicht mehr so antun oder ob das durch die Generationen durchgeht.
Wenn jetzt der VfB in der Relegation spielt, dann werde ich auch völlig emotionsgeladen dabei sein und den Verein unterstützen, aber ich tue mir das irgendwie nicht jeden Spieltag in der Bundesliga ein.
Andreas Lorenz mein Name. Ich bin seit über 30 Jahren hier in Berlin und schreibe seit 1987 über Hertha und seit erwähnte dann über Union. Die Jugend wird halt verschwendet an die jungen Menschen. Ihr seid alle so heiß mit dabei und seht manchmal vielleicht gar nicht, wie viel sich verändert hat und wie viel eigentlich auch erreicht worden ist. Als ich nach Berlin kam, ist hier jeder Schiedsrichter mit Nazi-Scheiße belegt worden bis zum Erbrechen. Jeder afrikanische Spieler ist beleidigt worden, bis die ganz wenigen Vernünftigen mit eingegriffen haben und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass der Fußball sich extrem zu einem viel schöneren, nicht Event, aber zu einem viel schöneren Erlebnis entwickelt hat in dieser ganzen Zeit. Ich habe vorhin zu lachen müssen, League of Legends. Ich habe einen 15-jährigen Sohn, der weiß, dass das 2.17. Finale von League of Legends im ausverkauften Vogelnest im Peking stattgefunden hat. Aber der weiß vermutlich nicht einen Verein aus dem Champions-League-Halbfinale, obwohl er auch Fußball anschaut. Aber wir waren doch genauso, wir verändern uns doch die ganze Zeit. Und ich wollte vorhin einen einzigen Satz merken, zur Generation Z habe ich unheimlich viele Sachen, die ich dazu sagen will, die nach 2000 geboren wollen, wollen unterhalten werden. Sie wollen mitmachen, sie wollen es nachmachen können. Warum ist TikTok das größte Ding, das es momentan gibt? Weil du dich irgendwie selber verarschen kannst auf 20 Sekunden, ohne dass du weißt, dass du dich verarschst. Und ich sage, du willst diese Tricks nachspielen, du willst die richtigen Klamotten spielen. Mein Sohn kennt Michael Jordan, seitdem der Jumper, der Jumpman jetzt wieder bei PSG auf dem Trikot ist. Und plötzlich laufen mir überall in der ganzen Stadt Jungs mit Michael Jordan und ich sage dann, ich habe den Spielen gesehen und dann fallen die unmächtig um und rollen sich weg, ne? Aber was ich vorhin sagen sollte, diese Diskussion über Fußballkultur, ich hatte den Nachteil, dass ich oft auf Pressetribünen zumindest mal auftauchen musste während des Spiels und habe immer versucht, mich dort zu entfernen, genauso wie ich Pressezentren hasse. Hasse wie ein Besuch bei der Schwiegermutter. Und Schwiegervater genauso. Du erlebst die Ostkurve, jetzt kann ich endlich mal in der Ostkurve stehen, oder ich stehe auf der Gegend gerade bei Union und das ist alles geil. Aber Fußballkultur oder das, was wir als Fußballkultur sehen, ist doch nicht das, was war, sondern das, was das nächste Spiel ist. Und wen wir damit hinnehmen und mit wem wir vielleicht hingehen, und wen wir als Freund dort haben und was wir dort erleben. Und deswegen halte ich mich mit diesen ganzen Negativen und ich habe bei Hertha einiges erlebt. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe das ja in einer Sekunde durchgespielt gehabt. Mein Opa hat mich 1968 mit zum ersten FC Nürnberg genommen. Das war die Meistersaison, danach sind sie abgestiegen. Also ich habe als Sechsjähriger alles erlebt, was passiert. Aber trotzdem, nach vorne denken, die Leute begeistern dafür. Und alles, was ihr sagt, ist richtig. Aber alles, was ihr sagt, ist auch einfach bloß ein Ausdruck der Zeit. Ich nehme meine Kinder, bis sie irgendwann mal Spaß dran haben mit. Die waren gezwungen mitzugehen, ganz einfach.
Ja, also ich bin Henry, ich bin auch bei Twitter unterwegs, ich bin derjenige, der den Jan Gobi vorhin angesprochen hat hier, wenn es um Thema Ostkurve und Hertha geht. Ich bin Herr Tanner. Eine Sache, das nur zur Erklärung, um den Jan vorhin einzuordnen. Nicht in der Ostkurve, nee. Ich will ja Fußball sehen und Hertha. Ihr seht doch, wie man das steht, ihr könnt ja nichts erkennen da drüben. Egal, darum geht's nicht. Es gibt ein Element beim Fußball, was natürlich wichtig ist zu erhalten. Preiswerte Plätze sorgen dafür, dass es zu erhalten bleibt und das ist das Thema, das normalen Chaos, das es im Fußballstadion gibt. Dass nämlich der Vater, der sonst immer ganz ordentlich ist, auf einmal richtig fluchen kann und schimpfen kann und den Schiri beschimpfen kann. Natürlich, sofern es sich im normalen Rahmen bewegt. Also nicht, wir reden hier nicht von irgendwelchen Unfleetigkeiten, aber einfach nur so, du dumme Sau und du hast doch keine Ahnung. Ja, das ist einfach ein Chaos, was ein Kind erleben kann, wie der gut situierte Vater auf einmal völlig aus sich herausgeht und seine gute Kinderstube völlig vergisst. Und das geht natürlich nur dann, wenn wir es uns leisten können, die Kinder weiterhin mit ins Stadion zu nehmen. Wenn natürlich ein Ticket in England einen absolut hohen Betrag kostet, wird es schon schwierig. In Berlin geht das alles noch, das ist wunderbar machbar, das ist bei Union genauso machbar wie bei Hertha, da kriegen wir es noch hin. Und ja, wir haben viel Platz bei uns im Olympiastadion, ja. Und wir nutzen den auch dementsprechend sehr kreativ und wir können auch Kinder wunderbar mit reinnehmen, das geht alles wunderbar. Deswegen nehmt eure Gören mit rein ins Stadion und lasst die richtig das Fußballerlebnis erleben und lasst die auch mal ruhig schimpfen. Und wenn die alten Säcke ringsrum stehen und schimpfen, dann ist das für die Kinder. Dann ziehen sie zwar den Kopf ein und gucken auf die Eltern und fragen, opa, ja, das machen wir zu Hause aber nicht. Ja, dann ist das eben so, ist nämlich Fußball. Und Fußball ist eben auch immer ein bisschen chaotisch.
Ich hab mir ja gewünscht, diese Diskussion über Fußballkultur zusammen mit Max. Wir haben das entwickelt und was ich jetzt wieder feststelle, wir reden wieder quasi fast ausschließlich über das Stadion-Erlebnis. Wir, die wir hier dieses Fußball-Film-Festival organisieren, das ist ein kleiner Verein, Brot und Spiele e.V., da sind Leute drin, die Fußball und Kultur, Fußball und Bildung fördern wollen. Und wir machen uns natürlich Gedanken darüber, wie kriegen wir eine andere Zielgruppe dazu, uns zu unterstützen, bei uns mitzumachen, eigene Ideen zu entwickeln und woanders hinzugehen. Genauso mit dem Festival. Wenn ich mich jetzt hier umgucke, was wir in diesem Podcast dann wahrscheinlich nicht hinkriegen, aber es ist wieder überwiegend, es sind Männer meiner Generation, mit ein paar Frauen dazwischen und ein paar Leute, die doch viele Leute, die jünger sind. Aber diese, über die wir jetzt hier reden, über die reden wir wieder. Also außer Marvin, der sich ja irgendwie selber älter macht, als er ist. Und deswegen meine Frage geht in die Richtung, wie können wir ein Kulturangebot außerhalb der Stadien? Gibt es da etwas, was man mit Fußball verbindet? Wir haben Ausstellungen, wir haben Lesungen, wir haben diese Diskussion und wir zeigen ganz viele Filme. Das ist Kino, da ist schwierig mit Stehplatz. Da sitzen die meisten. Das würde mich total interessieren, ob ihr dazu eine Meinung habt, was wir mehr machen können, inwieweit ihr uns unterstützen könnt, inwieweit ihr dazukommen wollt.
Ja, oder ja anders gefragt. Marvin, wo sind denn die großen Fußball-YouTuber? Zu fast jedem Bereich gibt es große YouTuber, große Influencer im Fußballbereich. Manu Thiele würde mir als einer einfallen, dann gibt es ein paar Medien, die versuchen, sich als Influencer zu positionieren. Aber wo bleiben die denn?
In Deutschland lassen sie noch auf sich warten. Ich glaube, wenn man nach England schaut, dann gibt es da eine Art von YouTubern, Club-YouTuber, sei es jetzt Arsenal, z.B. The Anfield Rap, bei Liverpool, die eine ganz andere Art zwischen Fan und Journalist auf ihren Verein blicken. Aber zu der Frage, wie man junge Leute außerhalb des Stadions begeistert, also ich glaube, so leid es mir um die Kultur geht, es wird halt irgendwo über Entertainment laufen. Und dann ist es halt tatsächlich für junge Fans eher die Netflix-Doku über Juventus Turin als aktuell die Lesung über ein sehr, sehr gutes Fußballbuch über Fußballtaktik von Tobi Escher. Tobi Escher erreicht die dann bei Rocket Beans TV. Also deswegen, ich fürchte, dass es da halt über Entertainment geht und wie weit dann Dokumentationen über Manchester City wie All or Nothing, wo ich sagen muss, dass die US-Varianten irgendwie im Football doch irgendwie mir da mehr gegeben haben, weil ich es authentischer fand als bei Manchester City. Aber das ist ja die Art, wie junge Fans auch Fußball konsumieren. Und es ist ja kein, es kommt ja nicht von ungefähr, dass auch bei den Freekickers halt die Fußballstars ein- und ausgehen, weil nämlich auch die Ausrüster sagen, naja, du gehst da jetzt hin, drehst mit denen eine Stunde, dann entsteht dabei ein YouTube-Clip und das ist irgendwie, das ist für uns relevanter, als irgendwie beim Intersport eine Autogrammstunde zu geben. Also da haben halt sich die Zeiten halt deutlich verändert.
Ja, Glück auf, ich bin der Jan. Ich bin halt zehn Minuten vom Duisburg Stadion aufgewachsen, aber mit Schalke sozialisiert worden, so vom Freundeskreis her. Und was ich festgestellt habe, ist einfach, dass ganz viel so in meiner Generation um Aufmerksamkeitsspannen geht. Von mir aus eine Stunde Anreise zum Stadion, dann vor Ort Abreise, eventuell, wenn man noch im Pkw unterwegs ist, noch mal länger, weil öffentliche Verkehrsmittel nicht funktionieren. Und das ist einfach für viele Leute in meiner Generation zu viel Zeit. So, da haben die keine Lust drauf. Die machen dann lieber zur Halbzeit die Sky-Konferenz an, gucken das, gucken danach noch vielleicht eine halbe Folge bei Netflix von der Doku und machen dann abends wieder irgendwas anderes. Und die Anzahl der Leute, die wirklich losgehen und sagen, okay, ich nehme jetzt eine Auswärtsfahrt mit, die kann ich bei mir, an der Schule konnte ich die an einer Hand abzählen. So, und das ist halt, glaube ich, noch mal was ganz anderes, weil auch der ganze Medienkonsum gänzlich anders geworden ist, als der vielleicht noch vor 20 oder 30 Jahren war, wo es vollkommen normal war, dass man wirklich sich auch hingesetzt hat und einen Artikel mal gelesen hat. Heutzutage ein Elf-Freunde-Artikel für viele Leute, die blättern da einmal drüber, lesen die Bildunterschriften und das war's. Danach ist halt die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne im Kopf vorbei. Nee, gut, das war's eigentlich schon.
Also ganz wichtig, immer so ans Kinn halten, hab ich mal gelernt. Den Mikrofon kann man vielleicht, naja bei euch nicht. Ja, nee, ich will auf deine Frage antworten. Also ich habe vor drei, vier Jahren angefangen, irgendwann so in die Podcast-Szenerin zu gucken. Ein bisschen drauf gekommen bin ich, weil die, Stephanie von Texifa gehen, weil die den State of the Union jeden Tag veröffentlicht haben und da haben sie dann auch immer veröffentlicht, dass sie mal wieder aufnehmen und irgendwann habe ich mir das angehört und habe gedacht, wow, das ist ja geil, da sprechen Leute über Fußball. Dann haben sie gesagt, nee, dann hat da irgendwann mal den Max vom Rasenfunk da gehabt, der Sebastian. Und ich habe gesagt, ach, kuck mal, Rasenfunk gibt es auch. So, dann hat er die Leute von Damenwahl gegrüßt, ach, kuck mal, gibt es ja noch mehr. Und dann kam es wirklich so, dass ich ganz, ganz viele Podcasts konsumiere und über ganz, ganz viele Vereine teilweise besser Bescheid weiß als die eigenen Fans da. Also, ich kann ihnen da manchmal was erzählen, und bei mir auf Arbeit, wenn ich sage, ey, bei Hertha, hier, was ist denn da? Hab ich dir nicht von gehört. Nein, die wissen auch Bescheid. Aber wie gesagt, es ist total interessant und deswegen bin ich auch Rasenfunk-Supporter geworden.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Und ich sag mal, das ist eine Sache, die kannst du hören, wann du willst. Da kannst du nach Hause kommen und erst mal noch deinen Fußball 2000 YouTube-Kanal konsumieren und danach den Podcast hören. Ich finde auch, das habe ich als erstes gesagt, bevor ich da gesessen habe, lebendige Zeugen sitzen da. Max redet heute zu langsam, weil ich 1,2 höre. Das ist ganz merkwürdig, du kannst es auch schneller hören. Dann dauert es nur 4 Stunden. Genau. Und ich sage mal, darüber kriegst du unheimlich viel Community und der Hass auf andere Vereine lässt richtig nach. Ich fieber teilweise mit Hertha mit.
Ganz kurz bloß, ich frag wirklich noch mal, bei was wir uns gerade unterhalten, weil es sind doppelt so viele Zuschauer in den Stadien als zu der Zeit, als ich das erste Mal nach Berlin gekommen bin, sind es zwar bundesweit, wenn ich es richtig erinnere, in der Bundesliga einen Zuschauerschnitt von unter 20.000 pro Spiel, inzwischen haben wir einen Zuschauerschnitt von 35.000 oder 40.000. Ich behaupte jetzt mal, dass nicht die Alten zusätzlich in Stadien gekommen sind, sondern die, die damals vielleicht so die Jungen waren, sind trotzdem mit in die Stadien gegangen. Und jeder von uns damals Mittelalten, jetzt Altensecken hat gesagt, die sind aber komisch, aber es wächst ja pausenlos nach. Also ich verstehe wirklich nicht, warum wir uns gerade darüber unterhalten, dass keine Jungen da sind. Es sind genug Jungen im Stadion, wir sehen sie vielleicht nicht oder wir beobachten sie vielleicht nicht. Und auf die Frage, wie kriege ich die Kultur hin, indem ich, das ist jetzt ganz banal und ganz böse, indem ich für Kultur sorge und tolle Fotografien, tolle Clips, tolle irgendwas mache, was auch passt, dass ich eben auch mit wirklichen Kori-Fan versuche, das Fußballerlebnis einzufangen. Und das haben wir ja auch vielmehr. Es gab früher keine Fußballfilme. Es gab Helmut Zorke, der ein Buch geschrieben hat oder sonst irgendwas. Diese ganze Kultur gab es doch überhaupt nicht. Sanderländel, I die. Früher habe ich dich getötet für so ein Doku. Sonst gab es doch alles nicht. Wenn waren es marodierende Horten, und die gab es übrigens wirklich. 89, Rotterdam. Eine der größten Straßenschlachten rund um das Länderspiel, das es je gab. Jetzt haben wir wieder ein Spiel gegen Holland. Ich bin momentan außerhalb des Themenkreises, über den ihr euch gerade unterhaltet, weil ich irgendwie eine andere Erinnerung, eine andere Vergangenheit und andere Fakten im Kopf habe.
Guten Tag, ich will eigentlich eher noch was Positives sagen. Ich habe die These, dass das, was sich im Fußball verändert hat, du hast am Anfang irgendwie von dem Bezug auf die 80er und 90er gesprochen, im Vergleich zu heute, dass das Teil einer gesamtgesellschaftlichen Veränderung ist. Ich nenne es mal die totale Durchdringung sämtlicher gesellschaftlicher Ebenen durch den Verwertungsgedanken. So das Kommerzialisierung könnte man es auch nennen oder der moderne Fußball. Und ich erlebe im Fußball, dass es da Widerstand gibt. Also ich bin kein Freund dieses totalen Durchdringung. Und im Fußball gibt es Widerstand dagegen. Also im Stadion oder in Diskussionen wie hier oder in Magazinen mit Freunden oder was weiß ich. In anderen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen gibt es den überhaupt nicht. Obwohl die die kommerzielle Durchdringung genauso stark dort stattfindet. Wohnungsbereich oder was weiß ich, Gesundheitsbereich etc. Sämtliche andere kulturelle Bereiche. Überall passiert genau das gleiche. Aber es gibt keinen großen Widerstand. Hier beim Fußball gibt es ihn. Und das finde ich ist ein positiver Gedanke. Oder ist meine Grundthese falsch, das kann man natürlich sagen.
Ich hab da nichts zu ergänzen, außer dass ich genau deswegen die Diskussion aufmachen wollte, weil ich wusste, dass ihr noch schlauere Sachen sagt als wir. Das öffnet die Perspektive.
Ja, hallo, ich bin der Kai, ich bin Fan vom ersten FSV um 1.05. Das war jetzt nicht so entertaining das letzte Wochenende, aber es war auch okay. Zwei geteilte Sachen und zwar, das hat Herr Streich auch schon mal angesprochen, wer hat denn diese Welt gemacht, in der wir jetzt leben? Das waren nicht junge Leute und ich weiß nicht, ich finde es ehrlich gesagt immer ein bisschen arrogant, darauf zu runterzuschauen. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht mehr derjenige, der jetzt wahrscheinlich hier unter Jugend zählt. Immer noch? Also ich bin 27, ich weiß jetzt nicht, mit 15-Jährigen, das ist schon nochmal ein anderer, also wie man dort Fußball konsumiert, ist natürlich auch eine andere Art. Aber die Kommunzialisierung, wer hat diese Kommunzialisierung eingeleitet? Das waren nicht junge Leute, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass das Opfer davon sind, weil ich konsumiere Fußball auch noch anders. Und dann muss man sich ja schon mal überlegen, wenn wir ehrlich sind, wollen wir im Stadion ja schon Entertainment haben. Die Frage ist nur, welches Level sollte dieses Entertainment erreichen? Und ich finde es auch eigentlich gar nicht schlimm, solange man das mit anderen Elementen quasi vereinbart. Wenn man sich engagiert, wenn man sogar noch politische Aussagen machen kann, in Form von Transparenten, an einem ziemlich hohen Publikum, also was sich an ein recht hohes und viel Publikum quasi wendet. Und wenn man dann auch noch mal gepflegt die Sau rauslassen kann, dann finde ich, ist es auch immer noch für junge Leute attraktiv. Wenn man mehrere Sachen vereint, es muss ja nicht immer eins zum Extrem sein, aber wenn man diese Sachen immer noch vereinen kann im Fußballstadion, und das kann man auch in der Bundesliga, in der Premier League sieht das anders aus, das ist richtig. Aber ich finde, so lange gehen wir in der Bundesliga auch noch einen richtigen Weg. Und das jetzt auch noch mal als Positiv.
Also ich hätte vielleicht doch Widerspruch zu dem Beitrag davor, weil ich teile sozusagen die Einschätzung, die du gemacht hast, aber ich sehe nicht den großen Widerstand. Also das ist ja das, was ich vorhin schon mal meinte. Ich habe so das Gefühl, mit zunehmenden Generationen, es gibt so dieses Gemurre, ist ja voll blöd, dass alles so durchkommerzialisiert ist, aber wo gibt es denn wirklich einen Widerstand? Und ich habe so oft in den letzten Jahren gedacht, es gab ja immer auch mal erfolgreiche Protestaktionen, dass eigentlich die Fußballfans eine echte politische Macht sein könnten, wenn sie daraus, also ich sage immer jetzt nur, statt irgendwie 12 Minuten Protest am Anfang eines Spiels, könntest du ja wirklich mal gemeinsam eine riesengroße Demonstration auf die Beine stellen, weil es einfach wahnsinnig viele Fußballfans gibt und wenn die zusammen auf die Straße gehen würden, wenn die einen Protest auf eine andere Art und Weise machen würden, als nur so ein bisschen symbolisch ein Protest, wäre da ja mehr möglich. Also vielleicht, sag noch mal ein Beispiel, wo du siehst, dass es einen erfolgreichen Widerstand oder ernsthaften Widerstand dagegen gibt. Ich meine, selbst die Montagsspiele werden ja nicht gestrichen, weil die Leute die Schnauze voll hatten und es geärgert hat, sondern weil sie nicht lukrativ sind. Also nachher auch eher aus genau diesen Verwertungsinteressen heraus, sich nicht als erfolgreich erwiesen haben, werden die wieder gestrichen und nicht, weil sich irgendwie Fenster gegengewehrt hätten.
Ja, du hast wahrscheinlich recht. Ich sollte wahrscheinlich das Wort Widerstand irgendwie abschwächen. Wir sind hier zum Beispiel in einem kleinen Kino, von dem es früher überall welche gab, wie dieses Kino. Heutzutage gibt es halt ein paar große, riesige Multiplexe und kleine Kinos wie diese gibt es in einer Großstadt wie Berlin, gibt es noch ein paar, aber auch viel, viel, viel weniger als früher und in kleinen Städten gar nicht mehr. Da gibt es keinerlei, noch nicht mal Morden. Wenn ich jetzt in meiner Twitter-Timeline gucke, dann sehe ich Leute, die politisch anders positioniert sind als ich, die sich aber gegen diesen modernen Fußball und gegen diese Kommerzialisierung trotzdem wehren. Das ist das, was ich mit Widerstand meinte. Es gibt ein Bewusstsein darüber, dass da irgendwie was vielleicht falsch läuft. Und auch eine Bereitschaft, sich dagegen zu äußern. Widerstand nehme ich zurück. War Quatsch.
So, eine Wortmeldung noch, dann müssen wir, glaube ich.
Also vielleicht auch nochmal Andreas und dir was, also das ist ja wirklich so, wir haben heute ja auch Möglichkeiten, tatsächlich kulturell tätig zu werden und gehört zu werden, ohne dass du groß was brauchst. Also ein Wordpress-Blog, der geht ziemlich schnell, sogar Podcasts kann man irgendwie relativ schnell aufnehmen. Also vielleicht auch mal die positive Sache ist, es gibt eine Art und Weise von Kultur, die sich entwickelt hat, die eben nur digital geht. Das war früher anders, wenn du früher irgendwie ein Fan-Sein machen musstest, brauchtest du auf alle Fälle eine Schreibmaschine, du brauchst jemanden, der ein bisschen was verstand und du musst es kopieren und dann muss es es noch irgendwo loskriegen. Also ich erinnere mich noch an Leute, die durch Kneipen gezogen sind und Fan-Seins verkauft haben. Das ist heute einfacher geworden. Also es ist eigentlich tatsächlich mit der Digitalisierung einfacher geworden und da gebe ich Andreas z.B. total Recht, wenn er sagt, wir sind ja eigentlich auf einem guten Weg. Also auch wenn du sagst Widerstand, naja vielleicht klar, es ist keine große Demo da, aber man kann sich auf alle Fälle organisieren und man kann Leute finden, die mit einem einer Meinung sind. Also ich kenne einige Leute nur von Twitter, mit denen ich jetzt irgendwie, hallo. Und das ist vielleicht auch die Sache mit der Kultur. Also vielleicht findet Fußballkultur heute auch ein Nischen statt, die früher gar nicht bedient werden konnten. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Also das ist vielleicht eben auch so eine Sache. Man muss die Nischen suchen und das ist manchmal schwierig, das gebe ich auch zu. Also es gibt manchmal, wenn man wirklich zum Beispiel einen Fußball-Blog sucht, findet man auch irgendwelche Leichen von 2012. Immer noch, manchmal ja. Ist aber auch ganz spannend dann zu weilen, zu sehen, was damals geschrieben wurde. Also ich möchte ein relativ positives Fazit eigentlich ziehen. Es gibt eine Fußballkultur, die sich entwickelt und die auch was damit zu tun hat, dass sich die Gesellschaft verändert hat. Und ich denke, die Sichtbarkeit, dafür müssen wir halt alle sorgen. Das ist dann wieder das andere Ding.
Ja, ich bin enttäuscht. Ich dachte natürlich, dass wir jetzt den Wikipedia-Artikel Fußballkultur komplett neu schreiben können und da noch drei Sätze drin stehen und dann haben wir es fertig erklärt. Nein, es ist so ähnlich gelaufen, wie man es erwarten konnte. Es ist ein riesiges Thema und jeder hat vor allem seinen persönlichen Standpunkt. Ich möchte euch ganz herzlich dafür danken, dass ihr nochmal unsere Standpunkte erweitert habt. Das war Sinn und Zweck des Ganzen. Wir waren ja eher so quasi die Anstoßgeber und das alles hätte aber nicht so gut ins Rollen kommen können, ohne meine beiden Gäste, bei denen ich mich nochmal ganz herzlich bedanken möchte und euch dazu herauffordere, dass ihr so laut applaudiert wie noch nie in eurem Leben. Ich danke sehr herzlich Katharina Dahme und Marvin Ronsdorf.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück um die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.